Speaker 1: Next question today, David.
Vaccination is going really well in the United
States.
Vaccines for everyone who wants them.
How much?
Credit does Trump get for vaccination?
Listen, he gets very little.
He gets very little, and what I mean is the
following Moderna and Fizer are companies
that existed in the United States long before
Trump and they were on the forefront of medical
science.
Johnson and Johnson, same thing.
AstraZeneca is, you know, different vaccines,
same thing.
So certainly Trump gets no credit whatsoever
for the fact that some of the usual players
were the first to get moving on vaccines that
would be used.
Trump gets zero credit for that.
OK, second question.
Who thought up the vaccines?
Well, you know, the truth is that back in
January, the virus was sequenced.
When it comes to the Phizer vaccine, Turkish
immigrants to Germany are the ones who actually
put together the building blocks of this vaccine.
It was ultimately developed and produced by
Pfizer.
Trump certainly gets no credit for that.
Now, what did Trump do?
Well, operation warp speed, operation warp
speed.
What Trump did is what any any any president
short of a true sort of genocidal psychopath
who wants to prevent vaccine development would
have done, which is what Trump made funds
available for companies that wanted to participate
in Operation Warp Speed.
The big manufacturers did not participate
in Operation Warp speed from a development
standpoint.
And then, yes, the government agreed to pre
purchase a whole bunch of vaccines so that
production could start even before we knew
which candidate vaccine is going to eventually
be the one that's used.
You can give Trump credit for that if you
want.
Any sane president would do that.
OK, so when we give him credit for that, what
we're saying is Trump didn't go out of his
way to make it more difficult to get these
vaccines produced.
And the reason you have to do this and the
reason this is so commonly done when you are
developing a medication for an urgent health
situation is if you wait until approval to
start manufacturing, you're behind.
So on spec, as we call it, you start manufacturing
vaccines before they are actually approved
so that if they're approved, you have a whole
bunch of them ready to go.
Trump allowed that to happen.
He didn't get in the way of that.
He can get credit for that.
He acted like a normal person on that.
On distribution.
He gets essentially no credit distribution
was a disaster.
When Joe Biden came in.
We were vaccinating eight hundred thousand
people a day.
There were vaccines that were unaccounted
for.
There was no plan turned over to Joe Biden.
It was an absolute complete and total mess.
So how much credit does Trump get?
He gets very little.
He, by downplaying the virus, reduced interest
in people getting the vaccine.
The distribution was essentially nonexistent.
Trump got vaccinated in January, didn't even
go public with that until March, at which
point two more months of building anti vaccine
sentiment had been allowed to fester and ferment.
So Trump gets extraordinarily little credit.
If you disagree with me, let me know.